the united states has now fully
vaccinated about eight percent of the
population
texas has fully vaccinated just under
seven percent of the population so of
course
republican texas governor greg abbott
has decided open everything
wide open end the mask mandates
and let her rip to quote anthony fauci
from last year
governor abbott tweeting about this
yesterday saying quote
i just announced texas is open 100
everything i also ended the statewide
mask
mandate he at the briefing made this
announcement
much the same way to applause take a
look at this
so today i'm issuing a new
executive order that rescinds most of
the earlier executive orders
effective next wednesday all
businesses of any type
are allowed to open one hundred percent
[Applause]
that includes any type of entity in
texas
also i am ending the statewide
mass mandate now did federal health
officials suggest this be done
no they did not uh federal health
officials said the opposite they said do
not ease restrictions quite yet
not enough people are vaccinated the
case reductions
are sort of leveling off this is not the
time to do that
but greg greg abbott doesn't care uh and
maybe uh
yeah i mean at this point maybe return
to smoking in restaurants as well right
if the argument here is freedom from
texas governor greg abbott now i have a
few thoughts on this
big picture this is completely and
incredibly premature
it's completely irresponsible it makes
no sense to do
that being said one element of this
is i wonder how much it will actually
change people's behavior in texas
because
all along you had lots of people in
texas ignoring the guidelines
and the people who are paying attention
to the cdc and fauci and the white house
are probably not going to change what
they're doing because of greg abbott's
announcement so
there's a real question as to how much
this will actually change in texas it
will change some things
i wonder how much that being said i can
understand and sympathize with the
urgency
of getting businesses open for the sake
of business
or at least wanting to the mask mandate
seems like just utter virtue signaling
to the anti-mask
crowd wearing a mask is so easy
you could open the businesses fully but
keep the mask mandate
and make it all safer so the mask
mandate ending
seems to me far more political than it
is even economic but it is texas and
that's clearly a big part of what
they're doing
the next question is whether this is
destined to backfire
what i mean by that is is it too early
of course it is
is it against the medical
recommendations is it against public
health recommendations what texas is
doing
of course are enough people vaccinated
where there's a mathematical case to be
made for doing this
no no chance in hell but
texas has the benefit of it being warm
in much of the state we know about the
storms warm in much of the state
getting warmer as we approach spring
just three weeks away
the virus is generally speaking on a
downturn
and vaccinations are increasing so as
bone-headed
as this decision is by governor greg
abbott
there is a chance that they may merely
by odds get away with this without as
big of a disaster as we might imagine
assuming that vaccination continues and
of course
the people most at risk who understand
the virus are probably going to keep
being safe anyway
so the case increases that this will
likely lead to in texas
probably are going to come mostly from
younger people
who behave less safely and will be
vaccinated later
but that might not be affecting
hospitalizations too much since young
people are unlikely to end up in the
hospital if they get sick
now some will some old folks will get
sick and die because of this
some random young people will too but
overall
texas has 29 million people
statistically
this is an irresponsibly early decision
to be making
but they might by chance get away with
it without as big a disaster as this
would have been if they had done it for
example
in october of 2020. this is the governor
making it official remember that the
mass mandate wasn't enforced in many
parts of texas anyway
people were already dining indoors so
it's quite possible that in some general
sense greg abbott is going to be able to
come out of this
vindicated and i use that term very
loosely thanks to the fact
that a lot of the guidelines the numbers
in texas already reflect a lot of
guidelines being ignored anyway
and vaccination and warmer weather is
only going to help that being said doing
this right before spring break
there's going to be some chaos and other
states clearly are starting to go in
this direction
a mississippi announcing yesterday
almost at the exact same time
they are lifting business capacity
limits they are lifting their mass
mandate and i predict there will be more
states to come
it strikes me as premature it seems to
me the more cautiously optimistic
timeline would be
let's go really hard the next 60 to 90
days on vaccination
and we could have for many aspects
aspects of the population in much of the
country
a close to normal summer maybe a lot of
states doing this will prevent us from
having that i don't know
but that's the news out of texas let me
know if you live in texas will you
change your behavior as a result of this
you can find me
on twitter deepakman one of our sponsors
is susman
and han sussman and han has everything
you need when it comes to
face masks and other supplies to stay
safe during covid19 and sussman and han
is the company that i've personally been
going to
for face masks and other ppe because i
trust the products that they sell and
that's actually why we reached out to
them about becoming a sponsor because
their prices are reasonable ordering is
simple
everything ships within 24 hours and
they just have
high quality products for this global
hundred year pandemic they've got
surgical masks kn 95 masks
n95 masks other useful things like
infrared thermometers face shields
sanitizers
susmen and han is also an awesome
company because they've donated
over 65 000 masks so far to health care
institutions
shipping is free on orders over 150
dollars you can go to their website by
going to davidpakman.com
mask the link is right underneath this
video and they'll give you twenty
percent
off when you use the coupon code david